[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
sûreté 1078 radio sensations
nous allons parler de la gauche
aujourd'hui il ya quarante ans le 10 mai
81 françois mitterrand était élu
président de république mais la gauche a
gouverné à d'autres moments il ya eu
évidemment les deux septennats de
françois mitterrand mais il ya eu les
cinq ans de gouvernement de lionel
jospin et les cinq ans de présidence de
la république de françois hollande on va
revenir sur ces passages de la gauche au
gouvernement tire et atteint les bilans
et puis on va parler aussi et surtout
peut-être de la gauche aujourd'hui
gauche qui semblent divisés peut-être
affaibli est ce qu elle a des
propositions est ce qu'elle peut
s'entendre
c'est ce sont des questions que nous
allons poser avec nos invités isabelle
this-saint-jean bonjour bonjour vous
êtes professeur d'économie à à paris
xiii vous êtes conseiller régional d'île
de france et vous êtes secrétaire
national du parti socialiste en charge
des études
sandrine grands groupes bonjour vous
êtes maire adjointe de trappes vous êtes
conseiller régional ile-de-france et
vous faites partie du mouvement créé
avec vaudois a manqué le mouvement
génération
ghislaine ce n'est bon jour alors vous
êtes vous êtes impressions du groupe
europe ecologie les verts au conseil
régional vous êtes donc conseiller
régional et vous êtes candidate est tête
de liste pour eux élevés pour les
régionales sur la liste menée par julien
bayou et puis avec moi en plateau
sébastien ramage bonjour bonjour vous
êtes vous êtes de la france à insoumise
vous êtes conseiller municipal de
guillon coup et vous êtes le candidat
tête de liste de l fille pour les
évident de folie ce chef de file avec
une liste une élite du tuc ancien maire
de la verrière du parti communiste
français en tête sous les yvelines s'est
allié avec le parti communiste et la
liste est menée par clémentine autain et
puis deux observateurs avec 12 en charge
en faire la joie ni bourges où vous êtes
vous êtes éditeur vous avez travaillé
fut un temps dans une autre vie j'allais
dire avec martine aubry mais peut-être
que la bouffe je t'adore j'ai croisé
martine aubry mais j'ai travaillé avec
jean poperen nuance jean poperen voilà
pardon c'était etc
c'était la gauche de 80 jean poperen
notamment et avec des idées très forte
sur la laïcité
et puis stéphane mention bonjour
mangeant pas 13 vous êtes professeur
l'université de versailles saint quentin
et doyen honoraire de la faculté de
boîtes cette même université alors on va
commencer par l'or
rappel historique il ya 40 ans donc
c'était le 10 mai 1981 là je vais me
tourner vers les plus anciens c'est du
connu 10 mai 4 vous avez connu ou le 8
mai 81 non j'étais pas n'était pas d
isabelle isabelle dessin valoir est ce
que quelqu'un de votre souvenir comme ça
du 10 mai alors c'est un souvenir
paradoxal parce que enfin d'une double
frustration jeu parce que
à quelques semaines près je n'ai pas pu
voter
voilà oui et de préparer mon
baccalauréat et donc le soir du 10 mai
et bah je j'ai fait enfermé dans ma
chambre tous mes copains faisaient la
fête à la bastille et moi j'étais en
train de bosser pour préparer mon bac
donc voilà c'est ça le le souvenir
personnel au delà de 100
c'est un sentiment enfin le souvenir
quand même de d'un horizon possible
il y avait comme le sentiment que oui
la puissance politique pouvait agir et
qu'il y avait une possibilité de
transformer le monde d'agir
politiquement et je crois que c'est ça
qu'il faut qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui
c'est que ça explique beaucoup de choses
notamment on y reviendra sur l'état de
la gauche aujourd'hui c'est que il ya eu
il ya comme un espèce de carcan d'une
espèce d'impuissance politique notamment
face aux questions économiques et que
d'une certaine manière on ne peut plus
changer la vie et ben moi je crois que
c'est complètement faux mais vraiment
complètement faux que bien sûr les défis
sont monstrueux chaque époque se vit
toujours comme historique
voilà je pense franchement que la nôtre
l'est et que c'est les filles on peut
les surmonter
mais il faut qu' il faut d'abord que on
en soit nous mêmes convaincus mais je
pense qu'il ya toute une nouvelle
génération politique qui on est
profondément convaincu et qu'on arrive à
trouver les mots
est-ce que je crois que nous avons les
solutions contrairement à ce qui est ni
on a pas opposition je crois que c'est
faux nous avons les propositions où il
reviendra sur l cela mais nous avons les
pros
position reste à convaincre nos
concitoyens que c'est le cas mais voilà
c'est ça mon souvenir de 80 aujourd'hui
alors c'est très bien ce que vous
devinez de dire parce que ça ça
introduit d'être d'abord le débat
historique et puis il débat actuel en
effet il y avait eu slogan qui étaient
tous 8,74 à d'ailleurs changé la vie on
avait l'impression qu'on pouvait changer
la vie on va se demander justement si
ben l'exercice du pouvoir n'a pas
peut-être encore accorder cette idée
mais d'abord si vous vous souvenir de 80
seraient de grands groupes
vous étiez moi j'ai souvenir familial
d'une trémie de gouttes qui est dans le
bonheur de voir enfin sa famille
politique arrive au pouvoir avec le
sentiment que les petits peuvent gagner
et que les puissants n'ont pas toujours
le dernier mot et donc c'est ce
sentiment d'allégresse et de fierté
retrouvée qui est moi me rappelle javier
j'avais dix ans j'ai vraiment se sentir
oasis le ce des mois par exemple moi
j'étais rigolo si j'étais à saint
germain en laye mon père était
fonctionnaire avait travaillé au camp
des loges et donc j'étais dans le monde
en une résidence militaire et je me
souviens au moment où j'avais 12 ans au
moment où l'image de françois mitterrand
apparaît pas vraiment un sentiment de
joie partagée aussi très très familiale
et mon père fermons la fenêtre quand
même et c'est parce que tu es assez
assez calme en fait tout autour de nous
mais moi le souvenir le plus marquant
c'est le lendemain en fait où je suis
allé voir ma ma ma meilleure amie en
fait qui est son père était
sous-officier est là l'ambiance était
absolument pas là mais merkel
qu'à la maison et moi je me souviens de
son père me disant que les chars russes
arriver réellement c'est un militaire et
pour lui les chars russes étaient à la
frontière de notre pays et moi c'est ce
sentiment là ce décalage qui m'a qui va
énormément frappé et cette angoisse en
cours pour ce militaire de carrière qui
pensaient que ça y est c'était la forme
la fin de notre pays c'était assez
incroyable
c'est vrai qu'il y avait l arrivée des
communistes et avec dany médiation de
quatre ministres communistes au
gouvernement
c'est stéphane et et jean-charles nous
aussi alors vous avez vécu vous êtes un
peu plus âgés que les autres un peu plus
un peu plus mûr visons un peu plus dur
j'étais jeune journaliste nouvelles
littéraires qui était situé rue
saint-antoine exactement 250 mètres de
la bastille et jean françois kahn
pressentant la chose avait réservé une
grande brasserie parisienne bofinger et
là ça fait une soirée de folie enfin à
tous points de vue mais journalistique
moi aussi et c'était vraiment une
une frénésie professionnels une frénésie
populaire et puis déjà ses passagers se
sont retrouvés 20 sert surtout à toute
une foule de gens qu'on allait à prévoir
dans les ministères des conseillères
déjà cette espèce de de gauche qui qui
qui prenait le pouvoir et qu'on allait
me fit qu'elle se retrouver partout et
il y avait déjà un petit décalage et
c'est chouette très populaire sur la
place de la bastille et puis chez
bollinger on était déjà dans une sorte
d' autres soit et je me souviens j'ai
passé la soirée notamment fin vous de la
soirée avec aragon et qui à l'époque
pour les gens qu'on présentait encore
quelque chose parce que dans cette foule
absolument indescriptible à un moment
vers minuit minuit tu me racontes
commence à être un peu fatigué il était
déjà un peu fatigué il a fallu le
raccompagner essayer de trouver un taxi
avec plus ça c'était il y avait du monde
dans la rue partout et j'ai fait
peut-être 500 m avec aragon
accroché à mon bras et c'était une
époque assez étonnant parce que tout le
monde le reconnaissait encore à l'époque
et je vois maintenant quand je parle à
mes étudiants aragon ça ne représente
plus personne ne savent même pas qui
c'est alors que à l'époque effectivement
aragon c'était quelqu'un voilà avec la
veille toute sa part d'ombré
mais voilà c'est principalement ce
souvenir
lisette d'urgence aurélien c'est un des
plus beaux romans de la littérature
française s'était fait de mensonges
parce que vous étiez vous êtes
professeur de droit public comme comme
jack lang et s comme lui vous êtes
passés de l'ombre à la lumière dès le 10
mai j'étais pas gt gt liste j'étais
collégien à l'époque j'ai peur vous
étiez pas professeur non non non jamais
j'avais 14 ans je veux une conscience
politique qui commençait à ceux à se
développer mais j'étais j'étais plutôt
circonspect circonspect au regard de 2,2
comment dirais-je des commentaires
qu'ils pouvaient que je pouvais entendre
ou lire çà et là notamment et ça a été
dit à propos
à propos des soviétiques qui était qui
étaient aux portes de la france avec
l'avènement la formule viendra plus tard
du du socialo-communisme ça c'est plutôt
dans les années 85 86 je je je m'étais
intéressé au personnage françois
mitterrand et ça m'étonnerait beaucoup
connaissent enfin ayant à l'époque déjà
pas mal lu sûr sûr sûr françois
mitterrand sur son passé sur sa culture
sur de ladoux il venait
je me disais que c'est que cette fable
était et est tout de même assez assez
assez forte et puis j'ai eu la chance
mais mais longtemps après là pour le
coup lorsque lorsque j'étais déjà
à une universitaire de rencontrer à
plusieurs reprises nicole questiaux qui
était qui était membre éminente du
conseil d'état qui a été dans le qui
était dans l'équipe de campagne de
françois mitterrand a quitté qui était
conseillère d'état qui a été ministre
des affaires sociales et kim avec
laquelle gg j'ai pu avoir une
comment dirais-je presqu'une un récit
historique extrêmement extrêmement
intéressant sur sur les coulisses et sur
sur l'intérieur des choses voilà
sébastien mathieu revient vers vous vous
étiez pas encore une idée en 81 mais est
ce que justement cette gauche unie dont
on parle est certaine les appellerons
socialo communiste mais est ce que c'est
une source d'inspiration ce qui s'est
passé nous avons 80 pour la gauche
aujourd'hui
alors vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure
sur les huit jours était d'ailleurs au
parti alors la gauche n'était pas
forcément unis à cette époque là par
contre vous avez cité le slogan changer
la vie oui c'était même changer la vie
ici maintenant son l'hymne du parti
socialiste et je pense que c'est ce qui
caractérise une gauche qui en capacité
de prendre le pouvoir
c'est ce truc là c'est non pas une
promesse d'un avenir éventuellement
radieux mais des mesures concrètes et
quelques semaines quelques mois après la
prise du pouvoir
c'est l'augmentation générale des
salaires la création l'impôt sur la
fortune
les 39 heures les la retraite à 60 ans
toutes ces avancées sociales sont des
réformes concrètes
aujourd'hui quand on entend réforme
généralement ça veut dire qu'on va
perdre des sous quelque part le mode
réforme a changé de la fête et je pense
que c'est pour ma génération de
militants en tout cas c'est ça que
représente 81
c'est que si on fait les premiers les
bonnes réformes et qu'on a des projets
qui nous permet d'aller de l'avant et
ben on sera en capacité de prendre le
pouvoir
justement isabelle this saint jean alors
vous parlez de de cet espoir c'est vrai
que il y avait cette idée moi je me
souviens de papier de jacques attali
notamment que la politique devait
dominer l'économie s'était pas
l'économie qui est qui et qui avait le
dernier mot et est en même temps quand
on est quand on gouverne on est face à
la réalité et sébastien rahman rappelé
les principales réformes qui sont
arrivés très vite mais très vite aussi
des gens comme jacques delors 10
il faut faire une pause aux réformes
sinon on s'en sortira pas c'est dire
est-ce qu à la fois cette idée est sûre
j'ai la vie ne s'est pas heurter au mur
de la réalité
non je crois pas parce que ça a
effectivement changé la vie il ya eu
effectivement comme le disaient nos
interlocuteurs précédents
ddd réformes qui ont changé la vie
quotidienne des gens donc ça c'est une
réalité ce qui s'est produit quand même
c'est que on a changé d'époque à ce
moment-là et qu' il ya eu des forces
qu'il faut qu'on analyse ou jean
ministère que il faut qu'on soit
réaliste mais réaliste par comme c'est
le cas parfois pour porter ces dites
réformes qui sont souvent
structurellement les réformes qui
dont vous parliez tout à l'heure elles
sont souvent dit structurel c'est en
général celles qui visent à renier la
possibilité de l'action politique pour
plus de justice sociale ou pour plus
d'écologie et pour aurait inventé la
démocratie mais on a changé d'époque à
ce moment là c'est à dire que ça a été
l'irruption de la mondialisation avec
son flot de dumping social et fiscal qui
s'est traduit par un affaiblissement de
la puissance publique par un
affaiblissement de sa capacité à porter
un état social donc c'est on sort à ce
moment là d'une période si on se remet
dans le temps long on sort d'une période
qui est celle des trente glorieuses on
rentre dans un autre temps et un tendon
à mon avis et c'est ça qui fait la force
de l'époque dans laquelle on est c'est
ça qu'il nécessite que tous ceux toutes
celles et ceux qui qui en ont un minimum
de courage s'engage politiquement parce
que nous sommes rentrés aujourd'hui dans
une nouvelle époque une époque avec des
enjeux qui sont des enjeux différents et
en particulier évidemment la question
écologique qui a fait irruption et les
les
les enjeux sont tellement important
convoi politiquement les conséquences
dire que là on risque d'être c'est la
démocratie désormais qu'il est d'être
embarqués si on n'arrive pas à redonner
à reprendre la main sur justement les
forces économiques le politique ne peut
pas renoncer
et alors il ya les bonnes nouvelles
quand même c'est ce qui se passe aux
etats unis
alors je dis pas qu'il faut prendre by
d'hommes comme modèle absolu de tout
mais on a avec bailly donne une page qui
se tourne
on a une page qui se tourne avec la
crise sanitaire celle qui a joué comme
un espèce de révélateur des
contradictions de notre époque mais avec
vahid
on a une page qui se tourne nous ne
sommes pas condamnés ni au populisme ni
à l'extrême droite et il y a dès lors
qu'il ya une volonté politique une
possibilité d'action pour plus de
justice sociale et pour faire face aux
questions écologiques et pour nous
réinventer la démocratie
on voit bien qu'on est dans une
cinquième république est à bout de
souffle quoi ça ne fonctionne plus cette
liberté en inox fonctionne donc bien sûr
ça il ya eu des choses qui se sont
passées mais je crois que aujourd'hui on
est dans un autre temps on est dans un
autre temps et que c'est ça qu'il faut
qu'on retrouvait donc venez nous aider
venez nous aider vous verrez que c'est
pas vrai que la gauche la proposition
parce que c'est vrai que vous travaillez
beaucoup contrairement à ce que parfois
on dit en quoi je voulais juste avant
d'aborder vous avez raison d'un parce
que c'est ça qui nous préoccupe c'est la
situation actuelle et c'est intéressant
de savoir peut-être que baydan va jouer
pour la gauche le rôle qui a peut-être
joué reagan il ya quelques années pour
pour la droite mais je voulais qu il ya
quand même eu le mur de la réalité
d'hier vient c'est quand même le
tournant de 2,83
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'il ya ce mythe de 80 mais
est ce que le mythe ne ne va pas contre
le mur de la réalité il ya ce tournante
83 on rappelle baisse du déficit
budgétaire des munitions du financement
des entreprises publiques soutien et les
pannes lutte contre le déficit du
commerce extérieur c'est à dire la
l'économie reprend un peu ses droits
quand même mais faut regarder ce qui
s'est passé avec la crise sanitaire
c'est quoi la crise sanitaire c'est à un
endettement qui tout d'un coup un
endettement public qu'est ce que l'on
est en pin est déjà extrêmement fort un
endettement public qui tout d'un coup
n'a plus de parler ne plus avoir de
limites pour permettre l'action
politique et ça quand même qui se
produit ce des déficits publics qui se
creusent et tous mes collègues
économistes aujourd'hui pour viennent du
fait que jamais la personne n'a été
aussi favorable pour qu'ils aient les
investissements une public structurel
majeur est que non le moment mais là
celui d'une austérité qui dirait pas son
nom et que nous il faut pas reproduire
l'erreur qui a été faite
l'europe au moment de la crise de 2008
moi je crois que 83 meta la preuve du
fait que nous sommes condamnés à
l'inaction politique là justement ses
cendres et de l'angor béotie cncd et
sébastien chabal
il ya eu d'autres périodes évidemment de
gouvernance de la gauche on va pas faire
que de l'histoire dans cette émission
mais c'est important notamment le
quinquennat de françois hollande qui a
provoqué les peut-être les scissions ils
sont aujourd'hui avec génération avec
avec la france est soumise
est ce que justement le
quand elle quand la gauche de
gouvernement se heurte à la réalité est
ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle est encore
elle même c'est ça la vraie question est
qu'est peut-être provoquer les six you
say des frondeurs jld c'est la france a
soumises et la montée de l'écologie
c'est peut-être c'est peut-être quelque
chose de différent s'entraîneront encore
ben je crois que les hommes et femmes
politiques intègres trop souvent leur
propre inaction leur propre entraves et
ne compte pas au goût de ce qu'il
pourrait faire et on nous c'est ce qu'on
a dénoncé et regretté lors du dernier
quinquennat de françois hollande sur un
certain nombre de sujets et tout à
l'heure il a bâti ce soir on disait
qu'il ya des nouvelles des nouvelles
réalités aussi autre que économique qui
s'impose à nous et qui a abandonné
doivent nécessiter d'avoir une réflexion
globale l'économie est un outil c'est
pas une fin en soi et dans les sujets
que l'on doit prendre à bras le corps
aujourd'hui qu'à la question écologique
mais geste n en parlera encore un peu
mieux comment on est sur un moment
particulier où il faut être en capacité
de prendre en compte les les changements
qui s'imposent à nous et pour lesquels
nous n'avons plus le temps d'attendre et
qu'on n'a plus le temps de se dire est
ce que le système économique est adapté
à ça c'est comment on adapte système
économique à nos nouvelles contraintes
qui se voit rouge oui mais alors vous
avez beaucoup critiqué françois hollande
le quinquennat françois hollande et sa
au boutis à quoi la candidature de
benoît hamon qui fait 6 % aux
présidentielles ça pose quand même un
homme un vrai problème politique ça je
partage pas du tout votre la manière
dont vous présentez les choses puisque
au moins le quinquennat de françois
hollande c'est ce qui amène à d'abord
emmanuel au pouvoir
c'est ça la réalité du bilan du
quinquennat c'est d'édition mais c'est
aussi l'arrivée de gamania dacquois dans
un contexte où la gauche a perdu en
unités en crédibilité et a perdu en
projet jsais de sonner alors justement
semble disais c'est vrai qu'il ya cette
dimension de l'environnement parle de
l'écologie de la transition écologique
qui est peut-être plus récente même si
notamment dans les élections européennes
les verts on fait souvent des très bons
scores mais là on a l'impression que il
monte dans les élections majeures comme
comme comme l'élection présidentielle
est-ce que ça c'est la donnée
essentielle qui pourrait regrouper la
gauche au fond la préoccupation
environnementale
je pense totalement qu'effectivement le
l'écologie en tout cas l'urgence
climatique pouces en fait une grande
majorité des du peuple de gauche je
dirais à aller vers vers un autre modèle
je crois réellement que c'est ce qui va
pouvoir redonner finalement un petit peu
de sens à l'action politique
moi ce que je voulais peut-être ajouter
sur sur le calque henin hollande c'est
que je crois qu'il ya eu une très forte
déception il y avait un tel décalage
entre le discours du bourget et puis
finalement ce qui a été mis en oeuvre
dans les politiques qu'il a menées
ensuite a été a été une déception
terrible réellement terrible et et alors
on nous a expliqué que c'était manque de
pédagogique voilà la politique menée
avait été avait été mal mal comprise or
il y avait réellement à part quelques
rares exceptions mariage pour tout ce
qui a été un élément fort de ce
quinquennat pour nous la loi à lui
remporté par par cécile duflot mais ça a
été jalonnée au fur et à mesure de
déception de renoncement à parler de la
loi du travail la cic mais des choses
aussi pour nous qui ont été terribles
débat sur la déchéance de
de nationalité tout ça a été vraiment
pour nous d'une manière très forte en
fait très très très très décevant et
puis gagner l'écologiste le rendez vous
manqué avec la question de l'écologie et
de l'urgence l'urgence climatique
on pense qu'il ya vraiment en fait la
gauche est vraiment sorti épuisé et
morcelé après après ce quinquennat est
il vraiment le renforcement en fait un
sentiment de défiance des citoyennes et
des citoyens vis-à-vis de la politique
et que aujourd'hui
alors on a vraiment envie d'une autre
société plus solidaire plus en plus
vives et plus respectueuse bien
évidemment du vivant ça c'est vraiment
très très forte et je pense que c'est ça
qui peut structurer réellement un
programme et est en tout cas un projet
de société et donc et donc moi je suis
convaincu bien évidemment que c'est que
c'est réellement autour de deux urgences
écologiques que nous avons la
possibilité dans les 30 années qui
viennent de pouvoir voilà construire
ensemble cette transition mais plus que
cette transition cette transformation
parce que et c'est peut-être là une
différence que que nous nous avons c'est
que robin nous nous pensons réellement
que nous sommes à un moment de rupture
et qu'il faut justement sortir de de ce
concept de réalité de pragmatisme
il faut aujourd'hui plus que jamais
vraiment entamée en fait d'aider
nécessaire politique publique de
transformation et de pouvoir avancer
vers vers vers un modèle une rupture en
tout cas plus plus radicale qui nous
permettra vraiment d'assumer le fait que
aujourd'hui voilà il faut changer de
modèle
il faut changer alors je vais passer par
là
jean le fallait et stéphane leur
demander leur regard d'observateurs mais
avoue je veux pas prendre la défense de
françois hollande mais il était
interrogé sur france inter pour
l'occasion du 10 mai 81 on lui demandait
s'il ya au second tour s'il ya macron et
mélenchon pour qui vous votez mais il
dit mais mélenchon il sera jamais au
second tour il est incapable d'être au
second tour parce que justement il ne
propose pas une politique qui peut
rassembler il propose une politique qui
n'est pas applicable
sébastien a dit françois hollande
en attendant je réalise justement mais
c'est vous le vrai problème de la gauche
y adhéraient au l'impression qu'il est
réaliste d'un côté des rêveurs de l'odm
éclairé veut dire on jamais au pouvoir
ils feront 6% comme un mot où il sera
capable d'être au deuxième tour où battu
par marine le pen comme les sondages de
guide pour jean luc mélenchon je pense
que si françois hollande se présentait
face aux électeurs il se ferait plier
par jean luc mélenchon s'en soucie moi
je réfute vraiment cette vision du
réalisme en politique
en tout cas du réalisme économique il ya
des économistes qui sont libéraux et des
économistes qui sont davantage
interventionniste que dans l'économie
était très bon kobe et moi je on parlait
tout à l'heure de cette scène aux bobos
enfin ge et isabelle this-saint-jean jeu
la joie ni parler de la scène aux beaufs
1 g ou juste après le 1er mai le 1er mai
la victoire du 10 mai 81
les mini se retrouve dans une espèce de
forme d'entre eux soit en fait la
première réalité que dont je pense
aujourd'hui le parti socialiste monsieur
hollande et toute une partie de la
classe politique est déconnecté c'est la
réalité de ce que c'est que d'être
chômeur dans ce pays que d'être ouvrier
dans ce pays de galérer à finir les fins
de mois et nous ses astra réalité là que
nous rattachons pour faire des
propositions concrètes et c'est à cette
réalité là qu'à gauche doit répondre si
la gauche ne transforme pas en
profondeur la société et qu'elle est
juste là pour gérer les affaires
courantes
elle a pas besoin de le faire est déjà
quelque chose qui s'appelle la droite et
qui fait ça très bien
mais notre rôle c'est de changer la vie
des gens sinon ne sert à rien et à ce
niveau là en terme de réalisme on a vu
mieux à la fois
ils n'ont pas après le tournant de la
rigueur en 81 83 ou à pendant le mandat
de françois hollande réussi à réduire
les inégalités dans ce pays au contraire
ils les ont aggravé et en plus de ça ils
ont fini par perdre et ça c'est bien je
pense la preuve que si la gauche ne
remplit pas son contrat qu'elle a avec
le peuple et bien
elle est destinée à perdre nous ce que
nous proposons aux français c'est pour
le coup un changement de paradigme
on l'assumé complètement nous ne sommes
pas dans la doctrine de réalisme de la
doctrine libérale
nous voulons aller à contresens à
travers notamment un deux trois outils
qui sont le service public et le service
public ça se financent par l'impôt nous
proposons quatorze tranches d'imposition
différentes et notamment un écart de 20
1 à 20 maximum et au delà de ça on prend
tous nous proposons l'augmentation des
salaires parce que il ya 10 points de
pib qui sont passés de la poche des
salariés c'est-à-dire de la rémunération
du travail à la rémunération du capital
depuis les années 80 et cette situation
là elle explique tout un tas de deux
drames des drames humains
je suis né juste là dessus et tous tout
ce dont on parle sur la question du
déficit de la sécurité sociale ou des
déficits de l'état
eh ben c'est dû à ce facteur initial
qu'aujourd'hui un très petit nombre
s'accaparent les richesses tandis que la
vaste majorité des gens galèrent à finir
ses fins de mois
et c'est ça qui met tous les compteurs
dans le rouge alors on va passer
justement la gauche aujourd'hui
[Musique]
peut-être de commentaires sur ce que
vous avez entendu stéphane moi je suis
je suis évidemment convaincu 83 on peut
rapporter les choses on peut rapporter
ces événements à ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui 83 été un tournant un
tournant fatidique c'est pas c'est pas
forcément le fait s'asseoir et de se
coucher devant les réalités économiques
s'est fait prendre à queue
des réalités tout court et des faits que
entre 81 et 83 la france était seule la
france était à total contre courant de
ce qui se faisait ailleurs et notamment
et pas seulement aux états unis ou au
royaume uni mais de ce qui se faisait en
europe et et c'est la démonstration que
au fond on july d'engins dans un monde
qui est totalement alors qu'on compte
qu'on trouve ça bien ou pas dans lequel
les états les puissances sont totalement
interdépendantes les unes des autres et
donc agir seul dans son coin
c'est vrai aujourd'hui pour les
questions écologiques et climatiques on
le sait pertinemment ça fonctionne pas
et et a fortiori quand on est à
contre-courant de ski de du reste du
reste du monde alors je sais bien c'est
aussi quelque part un aveu d'impuissance
mais mais mais je crois aussi que ce
décalage avec alors appelez ça comme
vous voulez
réalisme ou réalité il est aussi il
alimente la défiance vis-à-vis visage
hideux de la sphère politique ya ce
qu'on dit et puis est ce qui se passe et
quand l'un ne correspond pas du tout à
l'autre et bien les citoyens se
détournent de deux formations politiques
j'allais dire qu'ils restent dans le jeu
républicain qui sont à peu près j'allais
dire à peu près fréquentable et vont
faire vers les extrêmes que ce soit le
national-populisme d'un côté ou le
gauchisme populiste de l'autre donc ce
décalage entre les discours qui se
veulent c'est cette éthique de la
conquête du pouvoir et d'autre part
l'équipe de l'exercice du pouvoir
c'est quelque chose qui est vieux comme
la politique elle même mais qui on le
voit aujourd'hui produit toujours des
effets d'une très grande complexité
justement et il habite dit saint georges
reviens vers vous il ya une tribune est
publiée hier dans le jdd par jean
christophe cambadélis qui s'intitule
mitterrand réveille toi ils sont devenus
fous et qu'ils reprochent au fond à la
gauche dans son ensemble de ne pas tenir
compte au fond des problèmes qui se
posent aujourd'hui pour les français qui
sur le problème de l'autorité le
problème de la sécurité
est ce que vous êtes vous avez lu cette
tribune ne veux surtout c'est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec cambadélis
moi ça me rend triste parce que je pense
qu'on a vraiment besoin on est dans un
moment où quand même très très très
difficile pour tout le monde et pour
ceux qui se considèrent comme porteur
d'un autre horizon politique et donc je
pense que voilà plutôt que de distribuer
des bons des mauvais points et surtout
systématiquement des mauvais moi je
préférerais que ce soit des forces de
propositions ça soit des forces de
relais par rapport aux propositions qui
sont faites ça soit des forces d'
analyses montrent sur la réalité des
défis qui sont les nôtres
la compréhension des mécanismes et des
mécanismes de blocage
voilà moi je je préfère ce à quoi je
préfère ça les propositions il y en a
plein écouter ce que disent les
parlementaires de gauche et socialistes
notamment dans les hémicycles dans l'es3
et mystique vous verrez qu'ils sont
porteurs de propositions vous verrez que
le couplage entre une réforme fiscale
qui redonne des marges de malraux à
l'état social au service public qui
serait en part enfin de deux des sommes
considérables qui échappe à toute
fiscalité notamment celle des
multinationales
parce que c'est c'est ça les réalités
d'aujourd'hui avec la mondialisation que
ces propositions elles sont portées par
toute une nouvelle génération et que
donc ça ça redonne des marges de
manoeuvre
on a quand même avancé sur la question
de l'écologie ne serait ce que sur la
prise de conscience est l'actuel je
voudrais rendre quand même je n'ai pas
eu l'occasion de m'exprimer sur le bilan
du quinquennat olemps vous savez que le
parti socialiste a fait un travail louis
aussi sincère que monsieur bill ou en
actant un certain nombre de réussites
mais aussi un certain nombre de
difficultés
la déchéance la loi de travail mais dans
les éléments positifs
il ya quand même les accords de paris
qui donne un cadre alors bien suivre ça
ne va pas assez vite
bien sûr il ya une déception quant à
l'action mais le fait d'actes et ce
cadre qui donne une direction c'est
quand même quelque chose de très
important et donc moi je crois que il ya
eu une il ya une évolution possible elle
est là elle est sourde elle nécessite
qu'on discute entre nous à l'intérieur
de la gauche et que l'on sorte de cette
idée que il ya des divisions
irréductibles l'histoire des deux
gauches irréconciliables
les divisions irréductibles même à la
base il ya moi ça je n'y crois pas je
n'y crois pas je pense qu'il ya surtout
une gauche qui doit retrouver son
souffle qui doit réussira à se remettre
dans une dynamique et dynamique de
capacité d'entraînement et ça je donc on
a énormément de travail mais on a aussi
énormément de détermination ce que je
lui ai dit tout à l'heure la réalité
sociale est insupportable quand vous
êtes de gauche vous nous les tristes de
voir des gens dans la difficulté c'est
ça qui fait notre spécificité de ça nous
les tripes depuis toujours il y as a
cette force on l'a donc maintenant au
boulot
oui vous n'étiez pas de gauches
irréconciliables c'est elle et c'était
le propos de manuel valls mot fin là on
a la france a soumises
on a generation le parti socialiste on
allait vers et on voit bien que
d'ailleurs ne serait ce qu'aux
régionales et ce travail pour les
présidentielles duras il y aura une
vision des candidats mais je voulais
revenir justement si vous veut arriver à
cet objectif de réduction de la base de
40 % des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre
ghislaine ce n'est est-ce que ça passe
par la décroissance
en fait c'est pas la question de la
décroissance qui ceux qui se posent des
secteurs importants comment on fait et
on affiche pratiquement mais en fait le
vrai problème aujourd'hui qu'ils créent
autant d'inégalités c'est la croissance
c'est ce modèle qui fait que
systématiquement en fait on va
accompagner de manière statistique
développement d'un modèle d'un modèle
économique et que pour nous en fait il
faut organiser la transformation de
notre modèle de société tout en
réduisant particulièrement les
inégalités sociales en pratiquant l'art
eu l'occaz à sion massive la
transformation de notre société de
consommation et donc la croissance
en fait elle a été érigée en mythe en
totem absolue et ça produit tellement
d'externalités négatives qu'aujourd'hui
en fait un tout le monde est d'accord
sur le fait qu' on se dit que notre
société est arrivé là à apprendre à le
point de rupture
et est ce que l'on défend nous
réellement c'est un modèle différent qui
s'appuie sur des indicateurs comme le
niveau de santé de notre écosystème
sentiers sanitaires on le voit avec les
oppose et notamment le la commune et
puis d'autres indicateurs qui pourraient
être justement le bien-être le bonheur
de celles et ceux qui vivent qu'ils
vivent aujourd'hui et quand on parle de
décroissance nous on pense au contraire
qu'il faut injecter beaucoup plus
d'investissement plus que jamais en fait
dans les goûts
pour relever justement ces défis et moi
je ne crois pas que ce soit là de la
décroissance en fait c'est là encore
c'est prenez ce n'est que des enjeux de
communication et je voulais peut-être
simplement des mois je ne crois pas que
la gauche va aux os et aux plus en
difficulté par contre quel que la droite
républicaine aujourd'hui
en fait c'est vraiment laid partir parti
politique hongrois sur en difficulté
mais au delà de 100 il ya vraiment il
avait le disais je pense qu'il ya
vraiment tout cas une volonté de pouvoir
réduire
absolument ces inégalités sociales
totalement insupportable et que nous
aurons fait la jonction et je pense qu
on partage tous ceux qui sont présents
ici là même les deux les deux piliers à
la justice sociale
et puis à l'urgence l'urgence écologique
ensuite c'est une question curseur et
c'est ce qui fait peut-être notre
différence et voilà où est ce que
robaraud pas positionnés sur des grands
groupes
qu'est ce qui vous sépare d'europe
écologie les verts vous allez faire je
crois que benoît hamon et sur une liste
avec avec les verts pour pourquoi faire
deux mouvements ça c'est l'histoire
aussi c'est l'histoire de péter et les
parcours militant on va dire mais là ce
qui me séparent basse est rien puisque
j'ai le plaisir d'être aussi sur la
liste du coml ghislaine et on a on a en
partage un programme et une vision de
nous on veut aller et je souhaite la
constitution d'un pôle encore plus large
je pense que la course ne pourra revenir
au pouvoir que si on est les capacités
nous inde est tous dans le même parti
forcément mais de créer ces grands pools
de rassemblement qui permettent la
dynamique de victoires derrière et tout
à l'heure vous disiez il ya d'un côté
les réalistes de l'autre côté les
rêveurs moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
réalistes ce sont nous et les rêveurs
ceux qui imaginent qu'ils vont pouvoir
encore vivre comme dans notre société
des années 70
ce être repliés sur leur propre pré
carré et avantages en imaginant que rien
ne va changer
je pense qu'ils sont là dans l'illusion
total et les pragmatiques
aujourd'hui ce sont en réalité parce que
nous avons compris que notamment comme
l'a montré la crise sanitaire les enjeux
aujourd'hui c'est la question des
communs la santé l'eau l'air c'est la
question des services publics
et si on notera d elle en fait donc
c'est là où je dirai après en avance sur
tous les autres et que ça nous permet
d'être optimiste sur l'avenir de la
gauche après et le travail c'est le
travail de conviction et comment regrets
l'adhésion est comment la question de
l'engagement parce que je ne crois pas
au fait de dire venez simplement de cdd
travaille les coups on sait
qu'aujourd'hui c'est plus compliqué sage
je crois plutôt à ham en brousse
s'excite de dole compris auprès de nos
concitoyens et la question de
l'engagement aussi bien politiques
associatifs d'ailleurs et une protection
que l'on peut avoir parce que c'est être
là que le bât blesse pour alors ils
appellent this tout à leur parler des
des deux gauches il ya est conciliable
selon selon manuel valls jean charles
lajoie milliard il ya une vraie question
sur laquelle la gauche et est accusée
c'est la question de la laïcité et du
rapport l'islam
ben oui je pense que tant que la gauche
qui est éparpillé façon façon pulse ne
n'a pas un discours clair et quand je
vois le l'absence de discours ou alors
les paroles totalement scandaleuse de
plupart du temps de blanchons de nous
préserve qu'il arrive un jour au 2e tour
mais effectivement on voit mal comment
cette gauche éparpillée pourrait faire
front commun parce que y'a quand même
des gens à gauche
heureusement qu'ils ont quand même une
vision claire et nette de 2,2 ce que
peut être la laïcité de l'islamisme et
heureusement toute la gauche toute la
gauche n'est pas comme ça donc ça c'est
évidemment ça sera quelque chose
d'extrêmement important c'est un
marqueur il faut que tous les ans que
les écologistes que la france un sourire
va clarifier un peu ses propos c'est ce
qu'elle pense vraiment de de se prendre
deux sociétés qui est un problème majeur
et qui sera probablement
au coeur de la prochaine élection mais
je voulais juste aussi rajouter une
chose c'est que cette gauche éparpillée
bas les idées alors je sais qu isabelle
this-saint-jean travaille beaucoup sur
le sur les idées mais pour l'instant on
les voit pas beaucoup pas paraître mais
je n'imagine que ça va venir et du parti
socialiste mais ce qu'il faut aussi pour
pour la gauche c'est probablement une
figure et que mitterrand avec tous les
défauts qu'il a pu avoir et qu'il a pu
montrer etc
il était effectivement un type
brillantissime et derrière lequel on va
voir si importante
il ya peut-être je vais le regarder
quand même à sébastien ramage de ramon
de vous répondre sur justement le
rapport c'est vrai que vous avez enfin
le la france a soumis sais pas si vous
vous y étiez à participer à cette
manifestation contre l'islamophobie ça
lui a été beaucoup reproché c'est vrai
que parfois on entend dire qu'une
certaine partie de la gauche par crainte
en effet dû du racisme d'un mouvement
anti musulman est assez ne regarde pas
la réalité de cet islamisme on fasse
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ces
accusations
je pense que vous avez vite très
rapidement changer le sujet du débat
c'est dommage j'aurais bien voulu
répondre malaisie attention sur les
questions précédentes
je pense que les i et puis après on
reprendra ce qui différencie quand même
la france insoumise d'autres mouvements
politiques est ce qu'on arrive et réussi
je pense à réinsérer en politique c'est
la question du programme
la gauche ne pourra pas prendre le
pouvoir si elle n'a pas une pédagogie
une explication d'un ensemble de mesures
qui seront capables de changer
radicalement la vie je vous en citer
quelques unes j'aurais pas beaucoup de
temps pour nous parce que c'est là c'est
la sixième la question la sixième
république et de comment on refonde
notre démocratie
tout à leur disait que la vème
république dabou de souffle à laquelle
nous propose et que le parti socialiste
nous propose une mesure concrète
je veux dire est ce qu'on est capable
aujourd'hui de déterminer une seule
mesure concrète du parti socialiste
alors c'est pas le sujet du débat
mais lorsqu'elle travaille beaucoup les
eaux on en subit les conséquences
on subit les conséquences du séisme le
plan de relance par exemple ces deux
années de ces ice1 faut pas oublier 40
milliards d'euros mais si on fait en
déductions fiscales mange abaissé au
début du quinquennat de 2,2 d'emmanuel
bacrot peut-être en rendre le bénéfice à
françois hollande dans ce cas là si
celle ci ce qui a permis de faire
baisser le chômage
on estime à peu près que ces cent mille
euros par emploi créé à travers les
déductions fiscales du séisme donc nous
on propose un autre chemin non pas par
la réduction drastique des impôts parce
que de toute évidence ça ne fonctionne
pas mais plutôt par l'investissement de
l'état et la planification écologique
fait en sorte que la puissance publique
intervienne pour faire un certain nombre
de transition notamment dans le domaine
de l'agriculture par exemple sur
l'écologie ou le fait de supprimer les
produits phytosanitaires va nous obliger
à voir bien plus de main-d'oeuvre dans
nos campagnes de main d'oeuvre qu'il
faudra former pour pouvoir voilà faire
face aux enjeux maintenant sur la
question de la laïcité puisque vous y
venez plutôt parce qu'il faut aller jeu
j'aimerais dire une chose c'est que
c'est pas nous qui parlons de l'islam
matin midi et soir
d'ailleurs le pas en parler c'est
peut-être que d'autres en parlent trop
le sujet qui a été introduit là on parle
de laïcité mais on parle spécifiquement
de la question de l'islam
encore une fois toute la journée donc et
après on nous dit le l'islamophobie
serait-elle un fantasme je suis désolé
mais les débats qui sont à l'actuel
actuellement à la télé pour moi ils sont
généralement non pas pour réfléchir à la
laïcité mois plus tôt et tourisme qui
décale sérieux vous dites que l'islam
pose un problème en france rappelle les
propos que vous assumez maintenant je
veux juste revenir sur la capacité des
ssii par les islamistes c'est en tout
cas voilà un des reproches
la loi ne reconnaît ni ne subventionne
aucun culte ça c'est la loi de la
laïcité séparation des églises et de
l'état
j'aimerais rappeler deux choses sur la
question de la reconnaissance de la delà
de la religion
le fait que l'état ne reconnaissent pas
les régions garantit à la fois la
liberté de l'état parce que les
religions n'influence pas le poids
politique mais aussi la liberté des
religions parce que l'état n'a pas de
doctrine religieuse officielle
le fait est que c'est la droite qui a
créé le conseil français du culte
musulman donc c'est la droite qui assume
aujourd'hui d'intervenir dans la
question religieuse c'est la droite
les politiciens de droite qui chaque
année nous refont le coup de la baisse
le coût de la crèche à la mairie et de
dire 'voilà font la france est
chrétienne et sur la question de la
subvention c'est la droite aujourd'hui
qui est la plus grande défenderesse de
la question du concordat ou concrètement
l'état finance des lieux de culte et
c'est la droite qui a fait passer
l'ensemble des mesures servant à
financer l'enseignement privé
aujourd'hui c'est deux milliards d'euros
par an qui sont à travers des sportifs
comme la loi carle qui finance les
écoles privées oui bien sûr nous pensons
que l'école doit être obligatoire mais
doit être aussi laïques et républicaines
donc nous sommes pour le financement de
l'école privée e de publier public et le
privé se débrouille voilà il faut qu'ils
pardon je suis désolé mais on reprendra
si vous êtes d'accord ce débat c'est
passionnant mais on va parler très
concrètement
la nation juste bonne à la
présidentielle mélenchon il ira à coup
sûr de toute façon c'est ce que est ce
que quelqu'un pourrait incarner la
gauche c'est ce que même
et même si la gauche réunie elle est
quand même 28 30 % ce qui n'est pas
beaucoup mais est-ce qu'ils est vrai que
jean charles avait raison de dire il
faut une figure y incarne comment
comment régler ce problème rapidement
résumé on a on a très très peu de temps
il veut la journée moi je veux bien
je pense que on peut pas dans le même
temps dire il faut réinventer
profondément la démocratie et sortir de
cette 5ème république est à bout de
souffle avec cette hyper pérenniser
notre présidence utilisation et dans le
même temps vouloir absolument se
raccrochait figure moi je crois qu'on a
besoin d'une dynamique collective on a
besoin d qui est on a besoin que
l'ensemble des composantes de la gauche
se retrouvent et puis on faire un on
verra souvenez-vous qui aurait pas renié
françois hollande avant 2012 il était à
3% sont incapables a priori de gagner
les primaires
donc on verra et moi je crois que l'idée
dé qui est une idée extrêmement
puissante est extrêmement moderne parce
que on a besoin d'intelligence
collective vu la gravité et son jeu dans
lesquels on est donc la question ce
service nous c'est pas le petit gars
vous êtes d'accord avec ça c'est une
vraie langue embellissent le cd plutôt
une équipe qu'un homme provient une
femme providentiel je suis d'accord
celui des cons on en crève aujourd'hui
cette histoire
l'incarnation et que on a une démocratie
qui fonctionne serment par rapport à nos
voisins où on choisit d'abord des
équipes des programmes avant de choisir
un ou une femme et c'est quelque chose
qui a abandonné va falloir changer et
faire évoluer parce que le système
présidentiel a montré même combat crise
sanitaire tous et hynix encore plus
qu'avant
et donc là une des réflexions de
l'avenir de la gauche c'est aussi au
taux de hors jeu pas si c'est la 6ème
république ou pas mais comment on
transforme ces pluies
ghislaine oui non mais absolument pas
moi je crois que on a besoin enfin
certes dieu d'une équipe mais surtout
d'un projet fort qui pourra en tout cas
fédérer et changer la vie des gens c'est
ce qui nous semble le plus indispensable
et que et qu' il va falloir chacun que
chacun fasse face à un examen de
conscience c'est à dire qu'on a un mode
de fonctionnement aujourd'hui qui est
vraiment ancré sur sur l'incarnation sur
sur la personne qui puisse au mieux
représentés représenter un projet et
nous pensons qu'il faut déjà travailler
sur le projet nous un calendrier avec
avec des primaires qui vont se mettre
qui vont se mettre en oeuvre et qui
permettra en tout cas de pouvoir avancer
de manière collective c'est en tout cas
le lac est vraiment une dernière
question vous répondez par oui ou par
non
s'il ya un deuxième tour aux
présidentielles entre maquereau et le
pen
vous votez bacrot sandrine van gogh je
me réserve le droit pour l'instant de ne
pas répondre à votre question d'accord
parce que j'espère vraiment qu'on ne
sera pas le scénario
d'accord je dis cela j'espère que ce
sera pas non plus le scénario mais en
tout cas lorsqu'on est aujourd'hui sur
les marchés on se rend compte que voilà
il ya vraiment une volonté en tout cas
et une tendance à vouloir tester le rn
et donc s'il faut faire front contre le
r n ya aucun souci je voterai pour
l'autre pro vida isabelle même chose
c'est ras n'écrivons pas ce scénario
n'écrivons pas ce scénario c'est c'est
essayons de passer ce projet donc les
dents scénario alors alger républicain
s'il existe ou n'existe plus pardon le
front républicain il existe où il
n'existe plus maintenant on est si bien
sûr je veux dire ah j'allais oublier les
beats a besoin mais va il faut quand
même n'écrivons pas ce scénario atteinte
aujourd'hui sur les libertés publiques
par ce président de la république qui
était soi disant l'europe à sont quand
même extrêmement préoccupante donc
injustice atteintes aux libertés
publiques incapacité tracer le chemin de
l'écologie
il ne faut pas se résoudre à ça il ne
faut pas dire ça c'est bien moi je suis
effectivement très inquiète de voir que
vu son incurie et bien le bruit de
bottes se dessine à grands pas des
supers par les restes en suisse pour
finir important que pour répondre il ya
déjà allé sur le site du parti
socialiste
vous verrez que sur l'écologie sur le
travail sur la zone et sur l'éducation
ya à chaque fois un dossier complète
propagation donc arrêtons cette idée que
nous n'avons
y'en a proposé c'est faux c'est faux et
si vous voulez réinviter mois sur chaque
sujet ce qui nous ferait presque passer
des élections régionales et et je
voudrais pas prêt pour reprendre ce
débat sur les idées sur le fond ça
serait passionnant sébastien ramade le
pen macron je pense qu'il ya un
caractère assez anti démocratique à
avoir cette question comme seul horizon
donc je proposerai effectivement
collective est en tout cas un militant
politique nous nous cessions d'y
répondre sans cesse sur le plateau et
moyens d'éviter ce scénario là c'est de
voter pour nous aux élections merci cher
et était pas je suis désolé je peux pas
je peux pas vous un mot peut-être de
conclusion mermoud alors la gauche
je vais bien évidemment macron entre les
deux mais je m'aperçois que le fait de
cette question et quand absolument
terrible c'est terrible je veux dire
c'est effrayant de la part la france
insoumise de toujours dire
mélenchon nous l'a déjà fait comment
s'est fait non c'est non mais un peu sur
les talons et à gauche square rabin oui
pas de risque il ya une double fracture
à sion il ya une fracturation interne à
la gauche
quoi qu'on en dise qui est terrible et
puis il ya une fracturation par rapport
à l'opinion publique je dis pas par
rapport au corps électoral mais il ya
une droitisation du corps à victor
absolument en france et pas seulement
d'ailleurs dans bien d'autres états hors
pair dans bien d'autres démocraties
européennes
il ya une droitisation je ne dis pas
extrêmes droitisation g10 droitisation
le sans équivalent jusqu'à fin si on
monte
si on remonte en tout cas dans
l'histoire récente démocratique moderne
l'art contemporain merci merci à tous je
suis désolé parce que j'aurais bien
passé une heure encore de plus pour
parce qu'ils bloquent question est plein
de deux choses defour a examiné mais je
vous propose qu'on se retrouve peut-être
barreau septembre pour pourra parler de
tout ça merci infiniment isabelle
this-saint-jean ghislaine sonné sandra
une grand gaube
merci beaucoup sébastien rabat merci
beaucoup
azor-charles dhaouadi et stéphane
mongeau et à très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de port
[Musique]